- He's an American
recording artist and actor
from Cleveland, Ohio.
In 2009, his debut single Night and Day
reached the top five of
the Billboard charts.
He has sold over five
million digital singles,
and has worked with some of the most
prominent artists in the music industry.
He's Kid Cudi, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
- It's really just about the right timing,
and having some good stuff,
and just being creative.
'Cause that's half of the battle.
It's like, kids think that
it's just easy to get a deal,
that's not even half of it.
Getting a deal is very easy to do, it is,
but it's after that.
You know what I'm sayin'?
What you're going to do and
what kind of music do you have,
what kind of product are
you bringing to the table.
I think what made me get
to where I'm at right now
is because of the originality in the music
and the fact that I was
trying to push the envelope
on just everything, genres in music.
I think that's what
made me more noticeable
out of everybody else.
I always kind of--
When I grew up, I always
kind of felt like an outcast and (bleep),
you know what I mean?
Instead of being worried
about that (bleep) now,
I kind of embraced it and that's why
I made such a leap
creatively into my music.
That's why we are hearing about
me, because when I stopped
second guessing myself, and going in,
that's when I created Dat
New New and Day and Night.
I've been consistent ever since.
The mixtape, the album, all
the features I've been doing.
Ever since I made that change
within me, (bleep) been good.
At the end of the day, my mama told me,
"Don't let no one break me."
At the end of the day,
no one can ever stop me.
It's just like, those things are true.
Nobody can be the commander
of your destiny but you.
Only if you let somebody else take over.
But you always have the
power and have the control.
That's what people need to remember.
Day to day, it actually
sparks more minds and
has people wanting to be
more leaders than followers.
I think people are just
a little scared that
they'll lose the audiences'
attention, which is a real fear.
I get it.
It also goes back to what I was saying.
I've been blessed with
a fanbase that is into
what I'm doing no matter what.
That's just dope.
But the average artist,
they can't just experiment.
There's like fear, where
they might not sell records.
And then that's bad for
business, and this is a business.
So you know.
It's understood, why most
guys don't really do it.
I would like to see people do it.
I feel like that's not
an excuse, there's a way
where people can be a
little bit more creative and
push the envelope a lot
more with their music.
Where it fits in in a
way that makes sense,
is true to their art and their formula.
I feel like there's always a
way to try something new and
be innovative and bring
something different to the table.
Just Dre's whole thought
process, how he's so thoughtful
with the beats and to every
little meticulous sound.
I was inspired by that.
You hear that in my production.
My favorite producers are as follows:
Dr. Dre, Swizz Beatz,
Timbaland, Kanye West.
- [Interviewer] That's
your four right there.
- That's my four.
Of course, there's my
family, Plain Pat and Emile,
who are (bleep) phenomenal.
They eat humble pie every
(bleep) day they wake up,
so you'll never get it out of them,
but those (bleep) are geniuses.
- [Interviewer] No doubt.
- They had to be to (bleep)
with me in the first place.
To see it before I saw it
myself, what I could be.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, I'm
going into this project
thinking about those people.
When I want to add a sound at the end,
or when I want to switch the beat up.
I'm like, I used to love when
Timbaland would switch the
beat up at the end,
and it would just be a
whole other song down there.
Let me try to do my own flavor of that.
How could I recreate
and reimagine this beat
in the same song?
Or give them a sound in the beginning that
they won't hear until
they hear it at the end.
Just very meticulous, and strategic,
with a lot of the production.
I nerded out a bit, and
that was the fun part.
That I got to be a
straight up nerd on some
of the most aggressive
(bleep) hip hop (bleep).
I look at the genres as
different races in this game.
Hip hop is one race, rock
and roll is another race,
and R&B, and so on and so forth.
What I'm doing is trying
to end the segregation
between genres, you know what I mean,
and kind of just fusing them together,
and making it one super song, so to speak.
That's what I'm trying to do,
but just do it in a way
where it's appropriate.
Not just, I want to do
a record with this band
because it's a band, and
we need to fuse hip hop
with alternative rock because
it's a new thing to do.
I'll just go get this band
to do this hook for me,
and I'll just rap on
this rock and roll beat.
It's like, no.
That's been done before.
What's the next (bleep)?
We can fuse alternative
rock with some electro,
and still put hip hop on it,
and fuse all three of those together.
Maybe we can take some folk,
put some nice drums on it,
some hip hop drums, mix
it in with some country,
some guitar, you know what I mean?
And get someone like
Lykke Li to jump on it and
really kill it on the hook side
of things, give her a verse.
Give me a verse, we'll do a duet.
But at the same time, it's a
song you've never heard before,
with a sound that you've
never heard before either.
It's done in a way where
it's like, it's different
but it's believable.
It sounds good.
Kid Cudi has tried to
execute that (bleep) in a way
that nobodys ever done before.
I wanted to surpass Day
and Night ten times over.
I wanted to make this album
like it was my third album.
I wanted to go in and
just, no holds barred,
just come with it man.
People didn't know what to
expect from me because of
Day and Night just being
such a big success.
"This guy could just be a one-hit wonder,
"he could just have all these
really wack songs after this."
I love that pressure
and I kind of took that
and put it into my creativity.
Just really went in, made
some new sounding (bleep).
I find that when you have
your friends in the studio
you got a couple guys on World Star,
a couple guys on Twitter,
couple of guys over here,
and everybody's talking about
what's going on over here,
and what's going on over here,
and you're trying to write
this song, you get distracted.
You're like, "What happened,
aw hell no, that's funny!"
Next thing you know,
two hours have gone by,
still working on this record.
You had some laughs, but what you came
to the studio for is not done yet.
There's money being spent, there's time.
Time is of the essence.
It's w1hat we hustled and worked hard for.
I had to remind myself.
I was like, this turned
into a fucking party.
We're here for work.
So I also have this
really gnarly work ethic.
I've been working since I was 15.
My first job was Wendy's.
I remember why I wanted to
work, it was because I wanted
my own shit and I was tired
of asking my mom for stuff.
Also, I didn't think it was
fair to ask my mom for stuff.
I know we didn't have much.
Work for me, is always one of those things
that's very important.
I think it's important in
life to know who you are
in order to progress,
and that's what this album
is about, self-reflection.
At the end just being,
alright it's a new day,
it's morning, let's start right.
Being confident, and
that's ultimately what
Man on the Moon is, cuz that's the message
in this first installment.
- [Interviewer] What
does hip hop need to do?
- I think the braggadocio,
money, cash, hoes
thing needs to be dead.
(cheering)
I feel like, that's holding us back
as a culture, as black people.
It doesn't advance us in
any way, shape, or form.
We've been doing that
same thing for years now.
It's been what, like four
decades of the same old,
(bleep) sorry for my language.
And I feel like, if you're
going to be an artist,
there's a time when you just have to
embrace the responsibility and understand
that the power of music
is something so special
and be able to do it on this magnitude,
where you reach millions of people.
It's like, why not use that for good?
Why not tell kids something
that they can connect with
and use in their lives.
My mission statement since day one,
and I'm getting so worked
up talking about this,
all I wanted to do was help
kids not feel so alone,
and stop kids from committing suicide.
(cheering)
Thank you.
I never try to be political,
I'm actually shaking,
I can't believe I'm saying this.
- Those two specific things,
where does that come from?
- I dealt with suicide
for the past five years.
There wasn't a week or day
that didn't go by where I was
just like, you know, I want to check out.
I know what that feels like,
and I know it comes from loneliness.
I know it comes from
not having self-worth,
not loving yourself, and
these are things that
kids don't have music that can coach them
and give them that guidance.
I didn't have that.
I had to listen to Jay-Z and
take certain things from it,
and other (bleep) I just didn't know
what he was talking about.
(laughter)
Now I'm 30, and I'm like, oh that's
what hope was talking about, I get it now.
What about the kids that
never really had an artist
where you connected with
them all across the board?
I think that's my job.
I'm really just trying to
guide people and help people,
cuz loneliness is a terrible,
terrible thing, man.
If you don't know how to conquer
it, it can eat you alive.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because
Obina Ejoma asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Kid Cudi's top 10 rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.